thank you for joining us I'm John
langler we start up in the Northwest
Valley where rainbow is still closed
after this deadly two vehicle crash
early this morning it happened around
six o'clock near Rainbow and Smoke Ranch
you see the location there on your
screen right off us-95 so Metro Police
investigators tell us two vehicles were
involved now this is video from the
scene you can see that car is in really
bad shape that's sedan and this Republic
Services truck were at the scene there
we're not exactly sure of the connection
if there is one between them we just
know one person sadly has died we're
waiting for more details from Metro
Police this afternoon